[Música]
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva y es el nuevo
presidente de Brasil por tercera vez el
izquierdista llega al poder en sus
discursos inaugurales prometió unir al
país luchar contra la desigualdad y
reducir a cero la deforestación del
amazonía
este 1 de enero Colombia y Venezuela
inauguraron un puente que llevaba seis
años esperando para entrar en Operación
un paso más en la recuperación bilateral
de relaciones cortadas por completo en
2019 bajo el mandato de Iván Duque en
Colombia
el gobierno colombiano inicia además un
cese al fuego multilateral de seis meses
con cinco grupos armados ilegales la
guerrilla del eln y las autodefensas
gaitanistas de Colombia la organización
narcotraficante más grande del país
están incluidas en La tregua
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos esta emisión en
Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
juramentó el cargo de presidente en el
congreso para luego recibir la banda
presidencial en el Palacio de plan alto
frente a una multitud de miles de
personas en su discurso a los brasileños
pidió la unidad de la nación lo ha
prometido además profunda reformas Pero
ahora con el inicio de su presidencia
llegan también varios retos en un país
que enfrenta crisis múltiples desde la
división nacional hasta la política
exterior
es oficial Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
está de vuelta en plan alto por tercera
vez aunque ahora le espera un camino
plagado de retos uno de los principales
la profunda división de Brasil y no solo
en las calles donde la polarización es
patente también en el congreso donde el
partido liberal de bolsonaro tiene la
mayoría de 300 y es que para aprobar
proyectos de ley Lula necesitan más de
la mitad de los votos en la cámara de
los diputados y el senado Y al menos dos
tercios para modificar la Constitución
algo para lo que necesitará de su
capacidad de diálogo
en este 30 de octubre histórico la
mayoría del pueblo brasileño dejó Claro
que desea más y no menos democracia
Lula también deberá hacer frente a una
economía debilitada con una desigualdad
y crisis social arrastrada desde finales
del gobierno de Dilma Rousseff y
agravada por el ultraliberalismo del
gobierno de bolsonaro hay varias tareas
pendientes establecer una reforma
tributaria bajar el desempleo e impulsar
el crecimiento del país en la actualidad
cerca del 30% de la población del país
vive en condiciones de pobreza la
protección del medio ambiente una de las
promesas más sonadas durante su campaña
vamos a respetar nuestra nuestros
bosques
tampoco será fácil con la deforestación
de la amazonía en niveles récord lo más
complejo será protegerla sin dinamitar
su relación con el agronegocio
Solo quiero que me respeten como les
respeto yo a ellos el verdadero
empresario agroalimentario sabe que no
puede quemar en cierto lugar y que no
puede talar bosques donde no se puede
quemar
en la Esfera internacional el petista
carga con el peso de volver a situar a
su país en el mapa e intentar salir del
aislamiento al que lo abocó el
distanciamiento de bolsonaro con todos
los países progresistas de la región
todo para intentar acercarse al Brasil
que ha prometido a sus votantes
Colombia y Venezuela inauguraron un
puente que llevaba seis años esperando
para entrar en Operación es un paso más
en la recuperación de relaciones entre
ambos países que buscan impulsar la
frontera y así recuperar el intercambio
comercial que históricamente les ha
unido
comenzó el 2023 y Colombia y Venezuela
inauguraron el puente atanasio girardot
este estaba listo para ser transitado
desde hace más de 6 años delegaciones de
ambos países celebraron el hito
de prosperidad para ambas naciones para
Colombia y para Venezuela y muy
especialmente para la zona de frontera
estamos haciendo gala a la paz y hoy se
hace en este puente atanasio girardot se
hace de una apertura de nuestras vías el
26 de septiembre fueron reabiertos los
dos principales puentes internacionales
que comunican el departamento del norte
de Santander en Colombia y táchira en
Venezuela
con este inicio de año ha sido el turno
también sobre el río táchira de
latanasio girardot todavía quedará
pendiente la reapertura del puente José
Antonio Páez ubicado entre araucayapure
el atanasio girardot se construyó para
descongestionar el Simón Bolívar y el
Francisco de Paula Santander por los que
circulaban 30.000 vehículos diarios las
obras acabaron en 2016 pero en ese
momento el presidente de Venezuela
Nicolás Maduro ya había cerrado la
frontera por tensiones con el gobierno
de Juan Manuel Santos este fue el
antecedente a la ruptura definitiva de
las relaciones en 2019 cuando el
entonces presidente Iván Duque reconoció
a Juan guaidó como su homólogo y
calificó al gobierno venezolano de
Dictadura la llegada de Gustavo Petro al
poder en Colombia en agosto de 2022 ha
traído consigo la reanudación de
relaciones diplomáticas y de una
frontera que en su mejor momento alcanzó
el intercambio comercial de 7.000
millones de dólares en 2020 cayó a 220
millones de dólares Pero entre enero y
octubre de ya se recuperó hasta los 512
millones de dólares
también en Colombia el presidente de
izquierdas Gustavo Petro anunció el cese
al fuego bilateral con la mayoría de
grupos armados ilegales activos en el
país el cese se da en el marco de la
promesa de paz total de Petro sin
embargo son varios los retos de la
implementación de esta tregua que durará
seis meses
un año nuevo que arranca con esperanzas
de paz para Colombia el presidente
Gustavo Petro anunció en su cuenta de
Twitter el cc bilateral al fuego con
cinco grupos armados ilegales que durará
por lo menos seis meses hemos acordado
un cese bilateral con el eln la segunda
marquetalia el Estado Mayor central las
agc y las autodefensas de la Sierra
Nevada desde el primero de enero hasta
el 30 de junio de 2023 prorrogable según
los avances en las negociaciones la paz
total será una realidad
este anuncio es consecuente con una de
las principales promesas que el
presidente Petro hizo en campaña de
hacer lo que llamó la paz total con
todos los grupos armados una política
dentro de la cual reinició la
negociación con la guerrilla del eln en
noviembre de 2022 según el gobierno
colombiano el principal objetivo de este
histórico cese bilateral es suspender la
afectación humanitaria de la población
especialmente comunidades negras e
indígenas que habitan territorios
golpeados por el conflicto armado
interno sin embargo La tregua con estos
grupos armados ilegales es más compleja
que la alcanzada en el proceso de paz
con una extinta guerrilla de las Farc en
2016 organización en la que existía una
verticalidad en las decisiones y la
forma de operar es importante involucrar
a estos grupos porque Colombia en los
últimos cuatro o cinco años ha venido
transitando por una multiplicidad de
conflictos armados dejamos atrás los
conflictos de la guerrilla con el estado
y de paramilitares con el estado y ahora
Estamos en una multiplicidad de
conflictos en los cuales estos grupos se
enfrentan entre sí y con el eln Además
del del estado con el eln en estos
conflictos Colombia registró 92 masacres
en 2022 y 37 firmantes de paz fueron
asesinados en Ciudad Juárez en el
norteño estado mexicano de Chihuahua un
motíncarcelario dejó al menos 14
fallecidos los hechos tuvieron durante
las visitas por la celebración de año
nuevo en el centro de readaptación
social 3 de la ciudad entonces tuvo
lugar un tiroteo que según autoridades
locales habría dejado al menos 10
custodios y cuatro recursos muertos
antes de que el ejército llegara a
calmar la situación
y el año 2022 cerró con cifras récord de
migración de ciudadanos de países
latinoamericanos hacia Estados Unidos
son personas que llegan especialmente
desde Venezuela y Cuba lo que ha
desatado una crisis humanitaria en
países de Centroamérica y en México
precisamente la frontera Mexicana con su
vecino del Norte es el punto donde más
se evidencia dicha crisis según la
oficina de aduanas y protección
fronteriza estadounidense en 2022 se
detuvo a un número inédito de más de
2,76 millones de indocumentados al no
dejarnos pasar lo que hacemos Es un
ayuntamiento de personas que no hacemos
nada y si no tenemos papeles no nos dan
trabajo y si no dan trabajo como
subsistimos Cómo llevamos la vida acá
realmente creo que una de las cosas que
puede solventar y abrir un poquito más
el ayuntamiento de personas es que no
dejen pasar Yo creo que el presidente
debe empezar un poco en
gente Pues que tiene acá de migración
que una de las cosas para que el país no
colapse de tantos migrantes es necesario
pues que nos abran las puertas nueva
alerta meteorológica en Estados Unidos
por un poderoso sistema de tormentas que
ya ha dejado inundaciones en California
unos 235.000 hogares se quedaron sin
electricidad en este estado y en el de
Nevada siendo Oakland una de las más
afectadas con las lluvias más fuertes de
su historia ahora se espera que las
tormentas dejen fuertes nevadas en las
montañas
ráfagas de Viento y más lluvias intensas
en otros estados
hasta aquí las noticias sigan conectados
[Música]